we are showing some of the aftermath of
overnight looting here in philadelphia
this taking place in the port richmond
section of the city
we are outside a walmart this walmart
saw hundreds of people
inside looting overnight and we are
looking
at the damage left behind this right
here an empty 65-inch
tv the merchandise clearly taken out of
it in the box just left behind
if you take a look at the items
scattered as we walk closer to the
walmart you're gonna see
there are clothing food items more empty
merchandise
boxes there are just things everywhere
in this parking lot things that people
dropped as they were running in and out
of the building
but we do want to give you a peek inside
because this door is propped open it's
one of the doors people were coming in
and out of overnight
you can see all the water rushing out
that's because the sprinkler system has
been going off for hours you're also
going to notice the noise
that noise is the fire alarms that is
going off
as well and it has been for a very long
time none of us
really know the answer as to why those
are going off and have been going off
for so long
but it has been happening for quite a
few hours if we come to the front of the
store
these two windows right here busted you
can see
all of the glass scattered on the ground
and these two windows they lead to a
break room
nothing in the break room to steal but
if you look inside the break room you
can see it gave them an entrance into
the building
and all the water inside from that
sprinkler system
going off and non-stop we also have
taken a look at some of the other
shopping complexes here
in port richmond as well uh a lot of the
big box stores
like this walmart also seeing a lot of
destruction
and damage from kelsey fabian in
philadelphia